bonsoir à tous la séance est
ouverte j'informe l'assemblée que j'ai
pris acte du dépôt le 14 décembre 2023 à
17h50 d'une motion de censure en
application de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution par Madame Mathilde
panot et 77 de ses collègues la première
ministre ayant engagé la responsabilité
du Gouvernement sur l'adoption en
nouvelle lecture de la première partie
du projet de loi de finance pour 2024 en
conséquence l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion et le vote sur cette motion
de censure
le premier orateur va être monsieur
Sébastien de Logu pour le groupe la
France insoumise pour une durée de 10
minutes
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre collègu je vais faire attention
à ce que je dis aujourd'hui parce qu'en
quelques semaines madame bon pivé passé
de VRP d'une armée étrangère à juge de
la censure des représentants du
peuple madame la Première ministre au
risque de vous étonner je veuxcère vous
remercier vous remercier car en
déclenchant pour la 21e fois l'article
493 vous donnez à quelqu'un comme moi un
simple habitant des quartiers nord de
notre si belles villes de Marseille
devenu aujourd'hui député de la nation
française l'occasion de venir vous dire
droit dans les yeux et pendant 10
minutes ce que des millions de
Françaises et de Français pensent de
votre politique et de votre gouvernement
oui ce sont des millions de Françaises
et de Français qui aim aimerait bien en
ce moment même être à ma place vous
savez celles et ceux qui font les frais
de vos décisions autoritaires que vous
leur pososer dans votre budget sous
votre gouvernement ce sont des millions
de Françaises et de Français qui ne
peuvent pas couvrir leurs dépenses du
quotidien pourtant essentiel à la vie ce
sont des millions de Françaises et de
Français qui subissent le poids de la
cruauté des sacrifices du quotidien ce
sont des millions de Françaises et de
Français qui voient les choses
qui voi les prix des choses simples mais
nécessaires exploser comme leur
nourriture leur logement leur charg
locative la cantine pour les enfants ou
leur activités Sportiv et tant d'autres
choses comme les vacances si seulement
il pouvaent y songer ce sont des
millions de Françaises et de Français
qui avec laavenue de l'hiver doivent
trancher entre ce chauffer et manger
correctement ce sont des millions de
Françaises et de Français qui savent
très bien bien qu'ils sont les premières
victimes de votre budget historiquement
autoritaire et bien eux madame la
Première ministre je vous assure qu'ils
ne vous disent pas merci et les 30
millions de travailleurs à qui vous avez
volé 2 ans de vie avec votre réforme des
retraites non plus car ils le savent
vous ne les écoutez pas comme vous ne
m'écoutez pas d'ailleurs en ce moment
vous ne les considérez pas bref vous ne
les respectez pas pourtant si vous les
écoutiez vous comprendriez ce qu'il vous
demande est légitime car il est normal
de vouloir une existence digne et donc
pour ça de vouloir un état qui protège
ses citoyens de la violence des marchés
financiers et pas un état qui protège
quelques-uns vos semblables des
millionnaires et qui voit l'inflation
comme une auèe de rentabilité si vous
avez un peu de considération pour eux
comme pour moi encore une fois vous vous
vous pourriez comprendre que ces 30
millions de travailleurs et
travailleuses sont celles et ceux qui
qui crée toutes les richesses que
quelques-uns s'acaparent et qu'il est
indécent que les plus pauvres d'entre
nous soient également celles et ceux qui
sont le plus maltraité enfin si vous
saviez ce qui est le respect vous auriez
honte honte de la brutalité avec
laquelle vous gouvernez honte de passer
en force ce budget au 493 honte de
refuser
systématiquement tous les débat toutes
les contradictions sauf pour diviser les
gens entre eux selon leur religion et
selon leur couleur de peau alors dans ce
budget sur lequel les représentants du
peuple ne débattront pas à cause d'un éè
493 vous vous vous avez honteusement
décidé de mettre fin au bouclier
tarifaire alors que l'augment
l'augmentation des prix continue avec
une hausse de l'électricité de 31 % en
18 mois et que vous ne proposez rien
vous ne vous ni pour la combattre ni
pour protéger celles et ceux qui en sont
victimes dans ce budget alors que l'État
doit garantir à toutes et tous un
enseignement
public permettant l'émancipation des
consciences libres vous avez
honteusement décidé de supprimer 2500
postes d'enseignants et dans ma
circonscription où il y a plus de 40 %
des gens qui sont non diplômés où les
citoyens sont de demain font déjà les
frais de l'abandon de la République à
travers des services publics qui ont
totalement disparu vous avez décidé de
fermer huit classes avec la complicité
d'élus locaux qui qui continue de
s'enrichir sur la misère des gens et de
profit et d'en profiter pour détourner
l'argent public quel scandale quand en
même temps vous vous donnerz un budget
extraordinaire pour le service national
universel je vous le dis au lieu de
donner tout à tous les à tout les à tous
les jeunes des conditions
d'apprentissage digne au lieu d'ouvrir
des places dans les universités au lieu
de donner des fonds à la hauteur des
besoins pour les centres sociaux au lieu
de donner des logements dignes ou ou de
quoi se nourrir à ces étudiants qui pour
la plupart font la queue dans les
banques
alimentaires votre gouvernement fait le
choix de leur apprendre à marche forcé
la Marseillaise quelle priorité dans ce
budget enfin vous ajoutez à la dette de
la France une véritable dette
idéologique en refusant d'investir pour
une véritable planification sur tous les
thèmes vous échouez comme sur la
rénovation énergétique ou à au rythme
actuel il faudrait plus de 2
milliénaires pour rénover l'ensemble des
passoirs thermiques de notre pays dans
lesquels les plus précaires d'entre nous
continueront de vivre tout simplement
parce que vous repoussez l'interdiction
de la mise en location qui effectivement
ne plaisait pas aux multipropriétaires
et aux marchands de sommeil sur tous les
amendements proposés et votés par les
rest les représentants du peuple vous ne
retenez rien sauf pour arranger vos amis
comme l'amendement FIFA qui offre une
véritable un véritable paradis fiscal
aux fédérations sportives vous ne
retenez rien car soi-disant tout coûte
très cher rien pour les petites
retraites rien pour bloquer les prix des
loyers rien pour bloquer les prix des
produits de première nécessité rien pour
les aesh rien pour nos anciens qui sont
maltraités et qui pourisent dans les
maisons de retraite ce qui arrange bien
évidemment les vautours du privé vous
refusez même d'indexer les salaires sur
l'inflation pourtant la seule mesure
efficace pour protéger les travailleurs
et travailleuses de notre pays et en
même temps vous refusez de taxer les
super profits vous refusez de rétablir
l'impôt sur la fortune alors que la
moitié de l'augmentation des prix des
denré alimentaire est dû à une
augmentation scandaleuse des marges par
celles et ceux qui profitent de la crise
pour se gaver leurs actionnaires trop
souvent qui se retrouve sur ce banc de
l'Assemblée vous êtes tous très tout
simplement une farce face à
l'autoritarisme qui est votre méthode
face à la classe sociale qui est qui est
votre programme face à votre 493 nous
proposons de notre côté un contre-projet
de rupture car aujourd'hui la rupture
pour de nombreuses personnes pour toutes
celles et ceux qui vous que vous et
votre gouvernement méprisez c'est la
condition de l'émancipation c'est la
condition de la dignité c'est la
condition de la survie car au point où
nous en sommes avec les leçons de morale
déconnecté de la de la réalité la
rupture avec vous et votre politique ce
sont des choses simples ce sont des
choses concrète comme écouter les gens
débattre avant d'imposer par un éem 493
votre budget et vous pourriez mépriser
la démocratie comme vous êtes encore en
train de le faire pendant que vous ne
m'écoutez pas autant que vous le voudrez
le dégoût face à votre politique qui
pousse certains à abandonner ne sera
jamais aussi forte que la colère face à
ces conséquences qui nous poussent et
qui poussent d'autres personnes à
s'organiser et à agir depuis lundi
l'imposture de votre gouvernement est
flagrant et malgré l'ajout de centaines
d'amendements du rassemblement national
au projet de loi immigration vous avez
fait la preuve que vous que vous n'êtes
rien sans votre 493 alors madame la
Première ministre face à vous notre
groupe parlementaire présidé par
Mathilde Panau ici présente qui m'écoute
avec attention contrairement à vous ne
cèdera rien et continuera de vrai pour
l'Unité populaire et pour porter un
projet de rupture pour la paix et la vie
digne pour toutes et tous conformément
au programme de Jean-Luc Mélanchon en
2022 sur lequel nous avons été élus je
vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Véronique louvagie pour le
groupe les
républicains
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les les
ministres mes chers collègues sans
surprise la CMP de mardi dernier n'a pas
débouché sur un accord et sans surprise
encore madame la Première ministre vous
avez stoppé nos travaux sans nous
laisser le temps de nous exprimer en
discussion générale un 493 de plus le
21e je vous l'ai dit le dit et je vous
le répète ce n'est pas l'article 493 de
la Constitution qui en lui-même pose un
problème c'est la méthode employée par
le gouvernement rendez-vous compte
qu'entre la première sur et la nouvelle
lecture nous n'avons pu débattre d'aucun
amendement d'aucun amendement sur la
première partie du budget dans
l'hémicycle nous n'avons même pas pu
voter le moindre article de ce volet
recette et sur la seconde partie nous
avons seulement examiné 7 des 23
missions budgétaires et madame la
Première ministre il est pour le moins
paradoxal de vous entendre nous
reprocher de censurer le débat sur la
loi immigration quand vous avez
justement vous-même interdit le débat
durant tout l'examen budgétaire de cet
automne ne regardez pas la paille dans
l'œil de vos oppositions mais bien la
poutre dans celle de votre majorité
monsieur le ministre chargé des comptes
publics quand vous êtes intervenu à la
tribune jeudi vous avez vanté la méthode
du gouvernement avec un esprit
d'ouverture en justifiant avoir retenu
515 amendements lors de la première
lecture du PLF 2024 soyons sérieux
soyons sérieux vous n'avez retenu aucune
des orientations majeures que nous vous
proposions par ailleurs le 12 décembre
dernier Monsieur le Ministre par un
tweet vous satisfaisiez que le budget
2024 du Sénat a été adopté mais en 7h de
temps en moins de 7 he de temps en
commission des finances la majorité a
détricoté 150 heures de débat au Sénat
vous vous réjouissez d'avoir conservé
quelques mesures du Sénat mais combien
en avez-vous supprimé combien en
avez-vous modifié je vais vous donner
monsieur le ministre le nombre votre
bilan ce sont 55 articles du Sénat
supprimés par le rapporteur général ce
sont 13 amendements de réécruture du du
rapporteur général pour annuler les
apports du Sénat et revenir à la version
de l'Assemblée nationale ce sont 17
amendements du Gouvernement pour annuler
purement et simplement ce qu'a fait le
Sénat comment pouvez-vous encore parler
d'ouverture quand vous balayez d'un
revers de main du le travail qui a été
fait par une chambre pourtant connue
pour son sérieux et son esprit de
responsabilité je regrette à ce titre
que vous ayez rayer d'un trait de plume
les 7 milliards d'économies budgétaire
voté par le Sénat don au compte public
hautement déficitaire avait grandement
besoin mais le pire le pire dans la
méthode a été atteint avec l'amendement
déjà communément dénommé amendement FIFA
en première lecture déjà en catimini le
gouvernement a procédé à des cadeaux
fiscaux via cet amendement opportunément
déposé par les députés Renaissance dont
le rapporteur général et ceci quelques
instants seulement avant le
déclenchement du 493 il s'agit du régime
fiscal très accommodant pour la
trentaine de fédérations sportive
internationale reconnu par le Comité
international olympique et pour leurs
salariés heureusement le Sénat à
l'unanimité a supprimé cet ahurissant
cadeau inapproprié et incompréhensible
lors de la nouvelle lecture pour
l'examen en commission des finances la
majorité et le gouvernement ne sont pas
revenus sur cette suppression par le
Sénat et de ce fait aucun débat n'a eu
lieu en commission des finance mercredi
dernier mais stupeur nous découvrons
finalement que notre collègue Mathieu
lefèv déposé en séance le lendemain le
lendemain et en recevant un avis
défavorable du rapporteur général il
n'attire évidemment pas l'attention de
la commission des finances via
l'amendement l'article 88 et ensuite
quelle autre surprise de constater que
madame la Première ministre vous retenez
dans votre 493 cet amendement inique à
la veille de Noël à la veille de Noël
vous faites un gigantesque cadeau à
certains acteurs dont la situation
financière est pourtant excellente sans
que jamais je dis bien jamais la
représentation nationale n'est pu en
débattre madame la Première ministre
c'est absolument scandaleux vous avez
utilisé tous les artifices de manière
fallacieuse à votre disposition pour
éviter toute discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale sur ce sujet très peu glorieux
vous qui parliez de déis de démocratie
lundi vous nous en donnez un bel exemple
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre chargé
des comptes publicqus qui évoqué à cette
tribune jeudi dernier l'importance du
consentement à l'impôt et de la justice
fiscale où est justice fiscale et
comment prenez le consentement à l'impôt
quand vous faites un tel cadeau à
quelques privilégié quand la grande
majorité de nos concitoyens voir voi
leur pouvoir d'achat baisser et que vous
privez l'Assemblée nationale de pouvoir
délibérer sur ce sujet méfiez-vous
méfiez-vous de la colère silencieuse
après de telles manœuvres qui ne vous
grandissent pas revenons maintenant à
notre budget au budget que le
gouvernement nous propose pour 2024
d'abord hélas un tô prélèvement
obligatoires sidérant à 44,1 % du PIB en
2022 nos prélèvements obligatoires ont
atteint un niveau historique nous
plaçons au plus haut niveau niveau du
podium des pays européens et des pays de
l'OCDE ensuite un niveau de dépenses
publiqu exorbitant à savoir 55,9 % du
PIB supérieur de 8 points à celui de la
moyenne de la zone euro et que vous ne
faites rien pour contenir un déficit de
4,4 % du PIB qui fait qu'en Europe
seulement trois pays seulement trois
pays onuront un déficit public plus
important que le nôtre et de ce fait une
dette enfin qui continuera à augmenter
avec un recours à l'emprunt de plus de
285 milliards en 2024 un montant jamais
atteint qui fait que la France sera le
3è pays le plus endetté d'Europe
derrière l'Italie et la Grèce sachant
qu'au moment de l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron en 2017 7 pays avaient une dette
plus élevée que que la France et qu'ils
ne sont plus aujourd'hui que deux cette
charge de la dette qui va venir qui
était en 2021 31 milliards va grimper à
57 milliards en 2024 et elle pourrait
dépasser 81 milliards en 2027 ce montant
va devenir insoutenable je ne cesse de
le dire ce budget 2024 restera comme le
budget de tous les records en termes de
déficit et de dette pourtant les signaux
budgétaires devraient vous alerter vous
faire réagir la note de la France a été
dégradée par l'agence Fitch le 28 avril
dernier de AA en aa Mo et standard ONP a
placé la France sous surveillance
négative renforcée le président du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques lui-même
je le cite le PLF contient peu de
mesures d'économie structurelle alors
pourtant que le gouvernement nous
annoncé en grande pompe une revue des
dépenses qui a donc débouché sur rien ou
presque en 2024 les dépenses
continueront de progresser davantage en
valeur nominale que recommandé par
l'Union européenne et ce alors même que
la Commission européenne a annoncé la
fin de la clause dérogatoire général du
pacte de stabilité à comptter de
2024 la Commission européenne le 21
novembre dernier a d'ailleurs mise en
garde la France et trois autres pays qui
risquent de ne pas être en ligne avec
les recommandations budgétaires de
l'Union européenne pour l' l'an prochain
en raison de dépenses publiques
excessives le poids de la dépense public
n'aura jamais été aussi élevé que sous
les quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron il est
aujourd'hui deux fois supérieur à ce
qu'il était en 2019 et vous ne réagissez
toujours pas je vous le dis une anème
fois Monsieur le Ministre écoutez les
propositions du contrebudget des
républicain que vous avez toujours
refusé jusqu'à là à défaut de nous
écouter à défaut de nous suivre dans
cette ambition nous continuerons de nous
opposer à ce budget 2024 pour autant
vous vous en doutez il n'est pas
question pour nous de voter cette motion
de censure de la France insoumise car
nos idées nos convictions et nos
propositions sont aux antipodes de
celles de mathldde Panau et de ses
collègues la France insoumise qui
conteste même la réalité de la dette et
qui veut nous enfoncer chaque jour un
peu plus dans la logique démagogique de
la dépense du déficit comme si l'argent
magique tombait du ciel et n'était payé
par personne la France insoumise dont la
seule ambition est de taxer toujours
plus toujours plus les entreprises et
les ménages ù la transmission qui donne
pourtant une raison et une valeur au
travail ou encore taxer la réussite
comme si elle était forcément suspecte
et honteuse quand je pense quand je
pense à la gauche qui avec des députés
de la majorité a tenté mercredi soir de
revenir sur la baisse de la TVA sur les
centres équestres pourtant arraché de
hautees lutte comme si les enfants qui
ont le malheur d'Aimé faire du poney
était forcément fille et fils de
milliardaire enfin il est hors de
question de nous vous associer au
message envoyés par la France insoumise
à la jeunesse française de leur faire
croire que l'avenir est dans l'assistana
la décroissance l'endettement record et
le revenu universel pour toutes ces
raisons nous ne voterons pas cette
motion pas plus que les précédentes sur
les lois de finances mais ne croyez pas
madame la Première ministre que nous
cautionnons pour autant votre budget et
votre méthode ils sont tous deux
inacceptabl je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno milen
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate madame la
présidente madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
quel bonheur oui oui quel bonheur de
nous retrouver en ce samedi pour
débattre d'une nouvelle motion de
censure déposée par le groupe la France
insoumise je ne reviendrai pas
longuement sur la nécessité qu'à le
gouvernement de recourir à l'article 49
alinéa 3 dans le contexte d'une majorité
relative qui empêche tout vote
majoritaire sur un budget les Français
l'ont bien compris l'indifférence tant
médiatique que populaire dans laquelle
se déroule ce débat en est une preuve
cette indifférence voire pire elle va
même jusqu'à gagner vos propres rangs
puisque la mélanchonie est une nouvelle
fois seule à déposer cette motion isolé
au sein d'une gauche que je ne présume
aucunement en faveur du texte du
Gouvernement mais qui a bien compris que
cet exercice éculé n'avait que pour
seule conséquence d'affaiblir un peu
plus votre opposition encore une fois
tout à fait légitime au gré des votes
perdus l'élément nouveau dans le débat
par rapport à la dernière motion de
censure c'est ce qui s'est passé lundi
dernier dans le texte sur lequel
s'appuie aujourd'hui le dépôt de votre
motion de censure vous évoquez une
attaque contre la démocratie
parlementaire ou encore un dénis du rôle
du Parlement ces mots il correspondent
parfaitement à la manœuvre que vous avez
initié lundi
dernier avec l'extrême droite pour
empêcher notre assemblée de débattre du
projet de loi immigration débat que
souhaitent vivement les Français toutes
les études le monde l'argument que vous
avancez pour justifier votre refus de
discuter d'immigration dans l'hémicycle
c'est que ce débat a eu lieu en
commission et ben c'est aussi vrai pour
le projet pour le projet de
loi de finances dont les commissaires
concernés ont débattu pendant près de 6h
en milieu de semaine sans compter bien
sûr les jours et nuits passés sur la
première lecture vous êtes au final pris
à votre propre jeu et l'écrit d'orfraé
que vous poussez sur l'hypothétique déis
de démocratie que représenterait le 493
raisonne aujourd'hui comme un néant
d'hypocrisie et d'incohérence c'est
consternant finalement la seule surprise
de jour c'est le vote de extrême droite
l'alliance construite lundi dernier
entre la France insoumise et le
rassemblement national va-t-elle de
nouveau fonctionner
aujourd'hui assistera-t-on encore d'ici
quelques minutes à ces scènes
particulièrement gênantes de joie
partagé aux deux extrêmes de l'hémicycle
à la vue pardon excusez-moi à la vue des
rangs du rassemblement national j'en
doute un peu j'espère que vous ne serez
pas trop déçu du manque de mobilisation
de vos nouveaux
amis s'agissant de la position du groupe
vous la connaissez pendant des semaines
nous avons rappelé à quel point ce PLF
était nécessaire pour l'avenir de notre
pays nécessaire car une France sans
budget est une France à l'arrêt quoi
qu'en disent les oppositions la
nonadoption du budget serait délétaire
pour notre pays d'autant plus dans un
contexte de sortie de crise où notre
économie doit bénéficier de tous les
moyens nécessaires pour qu'elle puisse
se montrer aussi résiliente en 2024
qu'elle le fut en 2023 nécessaire car
celui-ci est porteur d'avancé sans
précédent en faveur de la transition
écologique de la justice fiscale ou
encore des collectivités territoriales
dans le texte initiale ont figuré des
mesures fortes dans ce sens la
transposition de l'accord de l'OCDE sur
la taxation minimale des bénéfices des
entreprises multinationale la réduction
progressive des dépenses fiscales brunes
ou encore une augmentation de la
totation globale de fonctionnement de
l'ordre de 220 millions d'euros le texte
de la nouvelle lecture est encore plus
ambitieux et ce grâce à des amendements
venants de la majorité comme de
l'opposition l'augmentation de la DGF
sera finalement portée à 320 millions
d'euros les règles de lien seront
assoupli entre la taxation
d'habilitation sur les résidences
secondairirees et la taxe foncière une
taxe streaming sera instituée pour
financer durablement la filière musicale
française contrairement à ce que vous
essayez de faire croire cette majorité
c'est trouver des compromis sur des
sujets cruciaux la recherche du
compromis n'est en aucun cas une
compromission au groupe démocrate nous
avons contribué à enrichir le texte mais
nous continuerons de défendre nos
convictions nous nous avons contribué à
enrichir le texte sur des sujets divers
nous avons souhaité élargir le champ des
contrats de rendre survie aux personnes
majeures dans la capacité d'acquérir une
instruction ou une formation
professionnelle d'un niveau normal nous
avons travaillé avec le gouvernement à
la prolongation d'un abattement
exceptionnel et temporaire sur les
plus-values immobilières et foncières
dans le casadre de session permettant la
création de logements sociaux nous avons
aussi souhaité créer la possibilité pour
les EPCI et les communes d'exonérés de
taxes d'habitation les associations
reconnues d'utilité publique les
fondations et les œuvres et les
organismes d'intérêt général par
ailleurs nous continuerons de défendre
nos convictions et nous espérons
convaincre nos collègues de leur bien
fonder dans les prochains mois on ne
lâche rien en matière de logement nous
avons des propositions fortes
j'évoquerai l'une d'entre elles pour
adresser une réponse systémique et
efficace sur le long terme à la pénurie
de logement nous en appelons à une
réforme structurelle de la fiscalité des
plusvalues immobilières qui ne
concernerait dans un premier temps que
les terrains AB bâtir l'abattement pour
durée de détention encourageant le
phénomène de rétention foncière nous
souhaitons le supprimer en imposant les
plusvalues à la flat taxe tout en
l'indexant à l'inflation en matière de
justice fiscale nous continuerons de
soutenir une vision singulière de
l'entreprise nous devons avantager les
bénéfices utiles et décourager les
bénéfices futiles dans ce sens nous
avons proposé en première lecture de
mettre en place une taxe sur les
programmes de rachat d'action des
grandes entreprises côté bien que non
conservé dans le texte final cette
mesure a été adoptée par deux fois en
commission des finances vous l'aurez
compris en respons ilité et sans pour
autant renier ses valeurs le groupe
démocrate ne votera pas cette motion de
censure représentative d'un jeu
politicien qui dure depuis plusieurs
mois du côté de l'opposition et qui a
pour unique effet d'abîmer de plus en
plus profondément notre démocratie
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Marietta Caraman
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
socialiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première
ministre mes chers collègues une mention
de censure est un acte habituel de
procédure législative même si
exceptionnel même si exceptionnel dans
un régime parlementaire classique reste
que nous ne sommes pas dans un régime
parlementaire classique la motion de
ceinsure y est la réponse un peu
standard si vous me permettez
l'expression à l'engagement du
gouvernement à lier son sort à un texte
qui n'a pas trouver de majorité pour le
voter ou qui a peur de ne pas en trouver
et fait pression sur son camp et ses
alliés c'est en effet madame la Première
ministre la 21e fois que vous forcez la
main du au Parlement et dans notre
système le chef de l'État qui domine en
tout la vie publique ne peut être
atteint par un vote au Parlement
qu'indirectement et la motion de cure
reste donc un moyen de dire qu'on se'
pose au fond il ne faut donc revenir au
désaccord de fond sur ce projet de loi
de finances initial pour
2024 notre collègue Christine prezbon
avait un premier lecture précisit la
position des députés socialistes et
apparentés premier point ce budget ne
soutient pas les Français les prix des
dépenses quotidiennes n'ont pas été
aussi haut depuis très longtemps l'État
cherche à compenser ce qu'il accorde
d'un côté mais il ne cherche pas à la
faire impuissant en puisant du côté des
plus riches ni dans les très grandes
entreprises la pauvreté n'a jamais été
aussi haute plus de 9 millions de
pauvres en France soit 15% de pauvres
dans la 6e économie du monde la plus
grande partie de la réduction de la
dépense s'explique par l'arrêt des
dispositifs exceptionnels instauré
pendant la crise énergétique et qui ont
profité pour parti aux petits ménages ou
entreprises et parallèlement l'État ne
en ne rehaussant pas de 20 milliards
d'euros ce que perd mécaniquement le
budget de l'État de fait de l'inflation
fait des économies un peu à l'aveugle
enfin l'affirmation des priorités
éducatives ou sociales ne s'accompagnent
pas des moyens nécessaires je pense à
l'école l'état reprend 2500 postes de
professeurs qui auraient été bien utiles
pour accompagner les enfants les plus en
difficulté qui sont souvent ceux des
familles les plus modestes je pense aux
universités qui accueille bon nombre des
étudiants les plus fragiles l'État
décide de de mesures qui ne finance pas
et s'abstient de préparer l'avenir ce
sont près de 2 milliards qui auraient
été nécessaires à celle-ci le deuxème
point c'est que ce budget ne soutient
pas la transition énergétique une
estimation née d' un rapport officiel
considère qu'il faudrait une dépense
publique de l'ordre de 34 milliards
d'euros chaque année d'ici 2030 pour
réussir la transition écologique
énergétique le gouvernement ne prévoit
que 10 milliards d'euros dont 7
milliards pour le ministère de la
transition écologique cela ne fait même
pas le TI pour y arriver alors même que
la non action sera encore plus coûteuse
et que des catastrophes sont devant nous
3è point ce budget ne va pas dans le
sens de la justice fiscale les calculs
montrent que ce sont 70 milliards
d'euros d'avantage certains diraient de
cadeaux qui ont été fait aux plus riches
et aux grandes entreprises au cours du
précédent quinquena se sont ajoutés 4
milliards de cadeaux supplémentaires
l'année dernière et s'y ajoute
aujourd'hui à ce nouveau budget 4
milliards cette année les quelques
petites taxes sur les secteurs qui font
les profits les plus contestables
n'atteignent même pas le milliard de
recettes les distributions de dividendes
elles n'ont jamais été aussi hautes
plusieurs études et proposition montre
qu'un qu'un impôt rénové sur la fortune
de très très riches rapporterait sans
crise ni préjudice 25 milliards d'euros
par an à minima les représentants de de
la majorité diront que les oppositions
s'opposent mais la discussion
parlementaire a bien montré que les
propositions des amendements des députés
socialistes et apparentés et cell des
autres groupes politiques ici de la
gauche étit dans l'ultra majorité des
cas rejetés notamment lors de discussion
en commission des finances je note ici
que le 493 est idéal pour un
gouvernement il lui permet de choisir
ses amendement hausse du SMIC c'est non
paradis fiscal pour la FIFA c'est oui
baisse de la TVA sur les biens
essentiels c'est non baisse de la TVA
pour l'équitation c'est oui baisse de la
TVA sur les transport en commun c'est
non baisse de la TVA sur les œuvres
d'art et les objets de grandes
collection c'est oui si les objectifs
donc Madame la Ministre madame le
premierre ministre d'une politique ne
sont pas partagés et qui ne fait aucun
cas de propositions allant dans le sens
des trois priorités mentionnées plus
haut on ne voit pas comment une
opposition de gauche pourrait bien voter
un texte à l'envers de ce qu'elle défend
à ce stade il paraît important de redire
que la plupart des projets de loi dont
émanant du gouvernement ont été votés
avec le soutien des voix de nos
collègues les républicains ce n'est pas
faire un jure que de le rappeler un
éminent historien a dit que l'actuel
président avait recomposé la droite et
qu'il en était la figure centrale c'est
vrai
nous sommes quasiment sûrs qu'un accord
entre les groupes de la majorité
présidentielle et celui des républicains
interviendra sur le projet de loi
relatif à l'immigration aujourd'hui le
493 suffit l'abstention de la droite
étant l'allié discrète qui permet de
durer une fois ça passe avec le
493 une fois avec l'abstention une autre
fois avec par un accord et le en même
temps institutionnel permet une
recomposition qui penche nettement
nettement à droite alors il est loisible
de créer une histoire dans l'Histoire en
mettant en cause la gauche mais au fond
sur les grandes orientations c'est bien
une politique de droite qui est menée
retraite budget
fiscalité liberté droits des étrangers
le basculement c'est déjà opéré et il va
continuer alors pour toutes ces raisons
nous voterons la de ceinure sans aucun
état d'arme je vous remercie de votre
attention merci beaucoup mes chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric Valtou pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
horizon madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur général
chers
collègues je suis ravi de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui comme t nous tous pour cette
ce nouveau débat d'une sur une nouvelle
motion de censure déposée par le groupe
LFI une de plus nous pensonsnous que ce
budget et je vais l'expliquer si on veut
bien m'écouter nous pensons-nous que ce
budget s'il n'est pas parfait répond aux
impératifs qui s'impose à nous d'abord
le rétablissement des finances publiques
ensuite le verdissement de notre budget
notre fiscalité ensuite l'investissement
massif dans la transition écologique et
le régalien soutient au pouvoir d'achat
face aussi à l'inflation surtout ce
budget comporte de véritables avancées
en matière de justice fiscale et de
lutte contre la fraude nous le voyons
tout tous au contact de nos concitoyens
en circonscription certains ressentent
un sentiment d'injustice ont
l'impression de fournir des efforts et
de respecter les règles tandis qu'ils
voient les autres s'en exonérer je veux
leur dire qu'il y a dans le budget 2024
de véritables avancées et qu'il ne
s'agit pas de survendre mais qu'il ne
faut pas minimiser je pense notamment à
la transposition dans notre droit de
l'accord de l'OCDE sur la taxation
minimale des multinationales fruit de
longues négociations dans dans lesquel
la France a joué un rôle majeur cet
accord est une étape essentielle vers
une coopération internationale renforcée
en matière de fiscalité la concurrence
fiscale entre les États ne peut se faire
sans règle et c'est par la négociation
et la coopération que nous parviendrons
à changer les choses à ceux qui nous
disent que le taux minimal de 15 % n'est
pas suffisant je leur dis que c'est une
première étape qui bien sûr en appelle
d'autres de la même façon cette
imposition minimale ne concerne que les
entreprises mais nous avons à cœur dans
les prochaines années de pouvoir la
transposer aux personnes physiques c'est
dans cet esprit que le groupe à déposé
et fait adopter un amendement visant à
engager plus concrètement la réflexion
sur la mise en œuvre de l'imposition
minimale internationale des personnes
physiques loin des postures démagogiques
et des effets d'annonce le gouvernement
et la majorité présidentielle sont à
l'action pour permettre des avancées
concrètes pour la justice fiscale la
justice fiscale c'est également la juste
contribution des acteurs qui ont
bénéficié des circonstances pour
accroître leur profit fidèle à notre
volonté de lutter contre les rentes nous
avons permis la prolongation l'année
prochaine du mécanisme de contribution
sur les rentes inframarg ginal des
producteurs d'énergie ce sont près de
500 millions d'euros qui pourraient être
récupérés par ce biaet de la même façon
il sera mis en place en 2024 une taxes
sur les concessions autoroutières et
aéroportuaires là encore pour éviter les
effets d'è liés à la conjoncture et
lutter contre les rentes œuvrer pour une
fiscalité plus juste c'est aussi lutter
plus efficacement contre la fraude ce
fléau qui abîme le consentement à
l'impôt renforce considérablement et à
juste titre le sentiment d'injustice et
grève les capacités d'action budgétaire
de l'État sur ce point le PLF 2 le PLF
2024 permet la transposition législative
du plan fraude présenté en début d'année
renforcement des pouvoirs d'enquête
durcissement des sanctions meilleur
contrôle des prix de transfert des
entreprises multinationales facilitation
des contrôles fiscaux les mesures
contenues dans ce projet il y en a
d'autres dans ce projet de de loi de
finance sont ambitieuses et nécessaires
pour passer un nouveau cap dans la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale vous voyez
chers collègues nous pouvons dire sans
rougir que la première partie du PLF
2024 permettra de réelles avancées pour
plus de justice fiscale dans la droite
ligne de l'action du gouvernement et de
la majorité depuis l'enchaînement des
crises qui nous qui nous frappe nous
nous mobilisons également pleinement
dans ce budget pour protéger nos
concitoyens et nos entreprises face à
l'inflation ainsi la sortie du bouclier
tarifaire sera lissée pour que
l'augmentation des tarifs de
l'électricité n'excède pas 10 % en
février prochain les aides à
l'installation des entreprises sont
reconduites et adaptées aucun pays n'a
fait autant pour protéger son tissu
économique et ses habitants face à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie aussi ce
budget mobilise 25 milliards d'euros
afin d'indexer les pensions de retra les
prestations sociales et le barê de
l'impôt sur le revenu sur l'inflation
c'est un effort très significatif qu'il
faut souligner le groupe horizon s'est
aussi fortement engagé pour que le
travail paye ainsi nous avons proposé la
suppression de l'impôt sur de l'impôt
sur de l'impôt que constitue
l'imposition d'une partie de l'impôt sur
le revenu à la CSG nous avons également
proposé la revalorisation du barê de
l'impôt sur le revenu à 5,2% au même
niveau que celle des pensions ces
mesures n'ont pas été retenues alors que
l'état de nos finances publiques ne nous
laisse que peu de MARG de manœuvre les
députés du groupe horizon fortement
attachés à l'ordre dans les comptes et
au rétablissement des finances publiques
comprennent évidemment des choix
budgétaires qui ont qui les choix
budgétaires qui ont été faits mais nous
prenons bonne note de la volonté du
gouvernement de mettre en reuve dans le
PLF 2025 l'engagement du président de la
République de baisse d'impôt de 2
milliards d'euros en faveur des classes
moyennes il nous faut continuer à
desserrer les taux qui leur donnent
parfois le sentiment de payer pour les
autres sans jamais recevoir de l'État
beaucoup a été fait depuis 2017 avec
plus de 25 milliards d'euros baisse
d'impôts sur les ménages et nous devrons
poursuivre dans cette voie quand le
contexte économique le
permettra ce budget est un budget
ambitieux en matière de transition
écologique au-delà des 7 milliards
d'euros de crédits supplémentaires qui
sont dédiés la première partie du PLF
consacre le verdissement de la fiscalité
notamment en prenant un Bral corore la
question la sortie de l'avantage fiscal
sur le gazol non routier je veux
notamment saluer la méthode qui a
consisté à proposer une trajectoire
claire et progressive de sortie de cet
avantage fiscal établi en concertation
avec les acteurs concernés ce PLF Consac
également le renforcement des
incitations fiscales à l'utilisation des
biocarburants ou encore le renforcement
des malus pour les voitures les plus
polluantes les traductions fiscales du
projet de loi relatif à l'industrie
verte trouvent également leur place dans
ce texte avec notamment la création du
crédit d'impôt au titre des
investissements en faveur de l'industrie
verte nous nous donnons ainsi les moyens
de réussir l'incroyable défi de
conjuguer réindustrialisation et et
décarbonisation et décarbonation enfin
et j'en terminerai par là le PLF 2024
marque le soutien renouvelé de l'État au
collec iité locale la dotation globale
de fonctionnement augmentera comme cette
année de 3 de 320 millions d'euros
l'extension du fond de compensation pour
la taxe sur la valeur ajoutée le FCT TVA
aux dépenses d'aménagement représentera
une hausse supplémentaire de 250
millions en faveur de l'investissement
local aussi et conformément aux annonces
que vous avez faites madame la Première
ministre un soutien complémentaire sera
apporté au département confronté à une
forte dégradation de leur situation
financière je pourrais citer encore
beaucoup de dispositions en faveur des
collectivités locales présent dans son
PLF mais je ne voudrais pas être trop
long vous l'aurez compris le groupe
horizon et apparenté considère que ce
PLF est un bon budget que c'est un
budget nécessaire qu'il est nécessaire
que la France se dote d'un budget
sérieux en s'étant tourmenté et donc
vous l'aurez compris le groupe horizon
ne votera pas cette motion de censure
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup mon chers
collègues la parole est à Madame Sophie
taayépolon pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste ah c'est
pas je sais pas plus
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues nous avons
assisté jeudi au 21e recours au 493
depuis le début de la législature
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ben ça veut
dire que le gouvernement gouverne seul
isolé comme dans une forteresse assiégée
sans le Parlement sans les corps
intermédiaires sans les élus locaux sans
le peuple ultime fantasme d'une élite
qui se croit éclairée alors qu'elle
participe à faire renaître les ombres du
passé persuadé qu'elle est seule à
savoir ce qui est bon pour le peuple et
qu'elle peut avoir raison contre lui
vous rejetez sur l'opposition la
responsabilité du blocage de la France
mais vous en êtes les seuls auteurs vous
nous avez même accusé avec l'adoption de
la motion de rejet contre votre projet
de loi sur l'immigration de refuser le
débat mais si vous aviez voulu le débat
vous auriez cherché à composer avec
celles et ceux qui ont appelé à voter
pour vous au second tour de la
présidentielle et dans tend de
circonscription au législative et ça on
ne peut pas dire que vous l'ayez fait
certes non vous êtes au contraire dans
une logique totalement opposée à la
nôtre coincé dans vos certitudes et vos
dogmes ultralibéraux vous ne voyez
qu'une issue qu'une pratique solitaire
et autoritaire du pouvoir bien sûr que
nous aurions voulu débattre du budget à
donner à la France que signifie ce
budget pour le quotidien des Françaises
et des Français il coûtera 2700 postes
de professeurs dans les collèges écoles
et lycées de nos enfants qui souffrent
déjà tant des absences non remplacées et
des classes surchargées il coûtera un
lit et un abri pour la nuit aux milliers
de gosses à la rue par un gel du budget
de l'hébergement d'urgence malgré toute
une société civile mobilisée il coûtera
aux victime du dérèglement climatique
les conséquences de votre inaction
sécheresse inondation et autres tempêtes
parce que coincé dans vos certitudes
vous n'écoutez même pas vos soutiens de
la première
heure tout ce qui a été pourtant
clairement détaillé dans le rapport
Pisani ferry mafous remis à madame la
Première ministre au printemps 2023 nous
aurions voulu débattre de la taxe
transport de longue distance ou de la la
réforme des redevances des agences de
l'eau pour laquelle in extrémiste vous
avez battu en retraite face au lobby de
l'agro-industrie nous aurions voulu
débattre du nouveau paradis fiscal pour
des fédérations sportives
internationales gavé par ailleurs
d'argent de médias privés nous aurions
voulu aussi débattre de ce que vos amis
centristes au Sénat ont voté une
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
hauts revenus à la hausse idée d'abord
portée par les écologistes et la nupes
ici mais le plus grave dans cet
isolement au fil des 493 qui s'enchaînne
c'est que vous entraîz dans votre
rechute la démocratie tout entière car
le débat parlementaire est au cœur du
modèle républicain de la démocratie
représentative chaque fois madame la
Première ministre que vous montez à la
tribune pour mettre fin au débat
parlementaire vous affaiblissez un peu
plus la démocratie à chaque promesse de
grand débat de plan banlieu de CNR qui
accouchent à chaque fois d'une souris
votre politique d'affaiblissement
démocratique se poursuit elle prépare le
lit d'une extrême droite qui n'attend
que l'effondrement du cadre républicain
pour prendre le pouvoir et ne plus le
lâcher mais ce mépris de l'Assemblée
nationale ne s'exprime pas seulement à
travers cette suite insensée de 493 car
il n'y a pas que le 493 pour vous pour
fouler au pied nos débats et nos
délibérations lorsqu'elles ne vous
conviennent pas j'en veux pour preuve le
texte examiné actuellement en Europe le
média freedom Act en janvier dernier à
l'Assemblée nationale nous avons débattu
et nous avons adopté ici une résolution
portant voie de la France dans le débat
européen sur la directive média nous
avons sur proposition de ma collègue
bouroua soutenu avec avec votre minorité
présidentielle une proposition pour
demander à votre gouvernement de porter
la défense absolue et sans équivoque du
secret des sources des journalistes et
qu'apprend-on grâce à une enquête de
disclose et une note du ministère de
l'Intérieur révélée par reporteurs sans
frontières et bien on apprend que le
gouvernement français exige en réalité à
l'échelon européen au côté des
représentants du gouvernement hongrois
qui espionne ses journaliste alors le
gouvernement français demande d'établir
une clause d'exclusion des questions de
sécurité nationale et de défense secret
des sources c'est cette clause qui a
value à la journaliste Ariane lavriux
une perquisition à son domicile par des
hommes lourdement armés c'est cette
clause qui a permis que son appartement
et ses outils de travail soient fouillés
que son téléphone soit saisi c'est cette
clause qui lui a valu un placement en
garde à vue par la DGSI après ses
révélations sur l'implication de l'armée
française dans le cadre de l'opération
Sirli c'est-à-dire dans des
bombardements de civils menés par le
gouvernement autoritaire égyptien du
général
Sissi notre liberté dépend de la liberté
de la presse
elle ne saurait être limitée sans être
perdue écrivait Thomas Jefferson en 1786
la liberté de la presse est au fondement
de notre démocratie et vous la bafouez
comme vous la bafouez comme vous bafouez
le débat
parlementaire je m'adresse je
m'adresserai volontiers à mes collègues
députés de la majorité si certains
étaient là qui tous ne peuvent se
retrouver dans cette compromission avec
la droite dure et dont certains je le
sais ont refusé de voter le mandat de la
commission mixte parent sur le projet de
loi immigration je leur diraiis s'ils
étaient là est-ce pour ça que vous avez
été élus madame la Première ministre
vous êtes affaibli par le vote de lundi
et voulant poursuivre votre entreprise
de délégitimation de l'Assemblée
nationale vous pensez que la meilleure
défense c'est l'attaque avec vos amis et
nous voici nous groupes écologistes mis
au ban des accusés pour une prétendue
alliance nupes Ren sur la motion de
rejet du texte immigration certains
responsables dans cette assemblée
menaçant même de nous tondre vous êtes
d'accord avec ça monsieur
dans une référence honteuse sexiste et
même je dirais dégueulasse voyez c'est
pas nous qui sommes prêts à brader nos
principes et nos valeurs dans les pire
concession à la droite radicalisée et
derrière elle à l'extrême droite
décomplexée à leur offrir des textes
purement idéologiques sur un plateau
d'argent comme disait madame la députée
de votre camp et espérer leur voix pour
faire adopter un texte indigne de notre
pays et de ses valeurs parmi lesquels la
fraternité le groupe écologiste ne
transige pas sur ses valeurs et nous
nous avions bien entendu au moment du
vote de cette motion de rejet les
déclarations de Monsieur daranin lundi
monsieur daranin vous aviez tendu à
plusieurs reprises votre main vers la
droite donnant votre accord pour revenir
dans le débat sur certaines dispositions
particulièrement honteuses qui avaient
été supprimées en commission méprisant
ainsi le travail de votre propre
majorité ce ne sont pas les écologistes
ou la nupes qui ont fort à propos la
veille du vote appeler des
parlementaires de droite en promettant
de nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
j'en profite donc pour vous dire
Monsieur daranin même si contrairement à
d'autres peut-être vous ne pouvez
espérer mon vote sur un texte qui
criminalise l'immigration et bien dans
ma circonscription on a besoin d'un
commissariat plein exercice ça fait 40
ans qu'on le demande à Villejuif et les
les habitants de cette circonscription
leur sécurité vaut autant que celle des
autres j'aimerais un commissariat de
plein exercice monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur mon mes chers collègues on
ne peut faire sans le Parlement on ne
peut agir sans le consentement du peuple
et de ses représentants on ne peut agir
dans l'opacité c'est pourquoi le groupe
écologique demande que le débat de la
CMP de lundi soit rendu public et c'est
pourquoi le groupe écologiste considère
que ce gouvernement ne mérite que la
censure je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Marc Tellier pour le groupe la
Gauche démocrate et
républicaine madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues même
l'intervention générale sur le projet de
loi de finances était de trop pour vous
ce projet de loi nous l'avons jamais
étudié dans cette hmicque concernant la
première partie et à peine quelques
missions budgétaires pour la seconde
alors je dis lorsque l'examen l'examen
en nouvelle lecture a commencé il n'y
avait très peu de suspense sur l'issue
pour autant lorsque vous êtes vous vous
êtes avancé à cette tribune madame la
Première ministre pour annoncer votre
21e
493 les représentants des différents
groupes n'avaient même pas eu le temps
de
s'exprimer même entendre les critiques
des oppositions sur votre texte étai de
trop malgré les éléments de langage
disyé depuis quelques jours et le rejet
du projet de loi inique sur
l'immigration tout le monde sait ici et
dans le pays que ceux qui n'aiment pas
le débat parlementaire c'est bien vous
le gouvernement et les députés de la
majorité vous ne supportez pas être mis
en minorité vous réagissez à la moindre
parole contradictoire à la moindre
opposition vous étouffez à la moindre
occasion et chaque jour par vos
manœuvres par vos coup de boutoir
procéduraux vous affaiblissez un peu
plus la démocratie Parlement mais aussi
la confiance que les citoyens ont pour
nos
institutions pour vous dépétrer de votre
mise en minorité la semaine dernière
vous avez osé dire que les Français
étaient favorables au projet de la loi
de loi imigration et donc qu'il fallait
le voter mais que faites-vous des 93 %
de Françaises et de Français qui refusai
haut effort la réforme des retraites qui
l'ont crié des semaines entières dans
les rues et que vous avez écarté par la
brutalité d'un
493 vous nous avez aussi accusé d'avoir
mêlé nos voix avec celle du
rassemblement national mais n'est-ce pas
sur leur banc que vous avez trouvé le
soutien nécessaire pour adopter la loi
l'OPM le projet de loi justice ou
repousser l'ourmentation du SMIG les
irresponsa c'est vous les cyniques c'est
vous les brutaux c'est vous une nouvelle
fois donc les représentants du peuple
français n'auront pas l'occasion de
débattre du texte le plus important de
l'année le budget de la Nation pourtant
la situation sociale de notre pays est
d'une violence palpable l'actualité
récente nous rappelle la situation
désastreuse de l'hébergement d'urgence
avec des dispositifs qui sont
aujourd'hui
embolisé depuis 2019 le nombre officiel
de plac d'hébergement du urgen n'ont pas
augmenté et plafonneent à 203000 une
anomalie alors que les besoins
augmentent mais pire encore le nombre de
places effectif lui est en chute libre
la faute d'abord à la sous-budgétisation
car les crédit inscrit ne permettent pas
dans lesffet de financer 203 203000
places en en ayant fait le choix de la
facilité et du court terme mais aussi en
refusant toute augmentation de crédit
notre pays fait face à une situation
sociale désastreuse avec 6000 personnes
qui doivent dormir dans la rue car les
services du 115 sont saturés à l'heure
où nous parlons ce PLF ne prévoit aucune
réponse à cette situation le deuxième
enjeu majeur de l'actualité c'est bien
entendu le pouvoir d'achat la chireté de
la vie accule chaque jour un peu plus
nos concitoyens 20 % monsieur le
ministre 20 % c'est l'inflation cumulée
en 2 ans dans l'Hexagone et c'est pire
encore dans les outres-mers face à ça
les salaires ne suivent pas et mettre
chaque jour un peu plus en difficulté
beaucoup de nos concitoyens on ne vit
plus dans notre pays dans de nombreux
cas de son travail comme le montrre les
2 millions de travailleurs pauvres il
n'est plus acceptable que nombre de
minima de branches soit inférieur au
smid ce PLF et plus généralement le
texte budgétaire constitue une nouvelle
occasion manquée pour agir de manière
contraignante sur les salaires nous le
regrettons cette situation conduit à
accentuer les inégalités économiques
inégalités que les réformes fiscales ont
largement contribué à accroître comme
l'ont montré nos collègues Matth et
sensu ces inégalités gangrainent
aujourd'hui notre société qui petit à
petit
redevient une société de rentier et
d'éritier une société figée qui ne
permet plus la mobilité sociale cette
situation se renforce encore quand on
assiste à la dégradation des services
publics 50 % des Français les plus
modestes ne possèdent que 8 % du
patrimoine privé pour eux le seul
patrimoine c'est souvent les services
publics c'est l'hôpital public c'est
l'école ou encore le logement l'INS l'a
montré la moitié de la distribution du
modèle social français passe par les
services publics or en continuant de
détériorer les services publics en
l'occurrence les services publics de
proximité vous accentuez un peu plus la
fracture entre les les Français que dire
également de la fracture entre le
territoire hexagonal et les territoires
d'outrem les crédits supplémentaires que
vous avez avit accordé à ces territoires
sont loin d'être suffisants pour paliier
les retards de développement qu'ils
subissent depuis trop
longtemps précarité du logement ampleur
de l'habitat àigne état des
infrastructures notamment routièr
obstacle à l'accès à l'eau potable loin
d'être de simples statistiques ces
carences profondes affectent le
quotidien de centaines de milliers de
nos concitoyens ultramarins la crise du
logement est particulier criante alors
que l'offre de logement est
dramatiquement insuffisante des milliers
d'habitants son en attente d'un logement
social que dire de l'eau cette ressource
fondamentale qui leur est encore in
inaccessible où sont les investissements
massif pour garantir l'accès à l'eau
potable pour tous pensez-vous vraiment
que 50 millions d'euros suffiront à
régler la crise de l'eau à Mayotte comme
tous ceux qui l'ont précédé ce budget
permettra r pas de renverser l'absence
de développement qui ronge les
territoires ultramarins la fracture
sociale dans notre pays nous inquiète
aujourd'hui au plus haut point c'est à
celle-ci que vous devriez vous attaquer
et non à celle créé de toutes pièces par
des théoriciens du Grand remplacement ou
du choc des civilisations bien au
contraire vous devez foncer dans cette
direec vous bien au contraire vous
foncez dans cette direction et ajouter
en plus une fracture démocratique entre
nos citoyens et leurs institutions en
multipliant les coup de force
antidémocratique en toute logique et
face à cette situation notre groupe
votera la censure du
gouvernement je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Benoît
mournet pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur général
du budget chers collègues nous voici
réuni ce samedi soir pour la motion de
censure que vous avez souhaité déposer à
la suite de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement sur la
loi de finances 2024 mais qu'ils aient
choisi d'envoyer dans cette assemblée un
député de la majorité ou de l'opposition
au projet du président de la République
les Français ne nous ont pas élus pour
bloquer les Français nous ont élus pour
travailler et pour agir les Français ont
souhaité souverainement cette assemblée
sans qu'aucun des partis n'obtienne en
effet une majorité absolue mais si
aucune coalition gouvernementale n'a été
possible
jusqu'ici nous n'avons pas davantage une
une majorité alternative hormis
effectivement d'improbables alliances de
circonstances de contraire comme vous
l'avez montré tristement lundi dernier
or chacun le sait la nation a besoin
d'un budget pour assurer les services
publics vous avez indiqué dès le départ
et avant même d'en connaître le contenu
que vous vous opposeriez au texte
budgétaire c'est votre droit la
constitution du général de Gaul a
justement prévu cette situation la
première ministre engage sa
responsabilité et nous la soutenons je
voudrais quand même ici rappeler que ce
fameux 493 que vous fustiggez n'a été
adopté que sur les textes budgétaires à
contrario 85 textes définitivement
adoptés avec des majorités et non des
moindres pour nos armées notre justice
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables le nucléaire l'industrie
verte l'emploi et le pouvoir d'achat
auquel s'ajoutent 30 textes d'initiativ
parlementaires dont plusieurs que nous
avons voté ensemble pour autant le
budget de la Nation 2024 avez-vous
seulement été prêt à en construire un
budget de compromis comme nous avons su
le faire d'ailleurs sous l'impulsion du
ministre pour la loi de finances de fin
de gestion 2023 la réponse est NON et
nous le regrettons mais il n'est pas
exact d'affirmer comme vous le faites
chers collègues dans votre motion que ce
budget serait le seul travail du
gouvernement les parlementaires de la
majorité comme des oppositions y ont
contribué un seul exemple porté par le
groupe socialiste et apparenté contre la
fraudte fiscale la généralisation des
aviseurs fiscaux ce projet de loi de
finance est un véritable texte
antifraude il prévoit plus de moyens et
de sécurité pour les équipes de contrôle
de nouveaux outils adaptés au numérique
et davantage de capacités pour
sanctionner les fraudeurs la navette
avec nos collègues sénateurs a été utile
également vous l'avez souligné madame
blouvagie elle a permis de corriger
grâce aussi à nos alerte de députés
ruraux le zonage du nouveau dispositif
France revitalisation rurale ou encore
de proposer un dégrèvement en faveur des
logements ayant fait l'objet de travaux
de réhabilitation de seconde vie ou
encore l'augmentation de la dotation
d'amorçage commune nouvelle mais si nous
n'avons pu conclure mardi soir en
commission mixte paritaire avec nos
collègues sénateurs c'est parce que ils
ont poussé leur soutien aux
collectivités territoriales jusqu'à
vouloir supprimer la mission
administration territoriale de l'État or
évidemment nos communes et nos communes
rurales en particulier ne veulent pas
voir disparaître nos préfets bien au
contraire mais vous avez raison vous
avez raison un budget voté a toujours
plus de force et bien mercredi soir en
commission des finances nous avons bien
voté et adopt cette loi de finances 2024
et cette motion aujourd'hui c'est son
intérêt à nos yeux et bien nous permet
de voter pour ou contre ce budget 2024
en séance publique vous êtes dans
l'oppos I et vous vous opposez nous
sommes dans l'action et ce projet de loi
de finance 2024 est bien un budget
d'action et de responsabilité car ne
vous en déplaise mes chers collègues
nous avons une responsabilité collective
vis-à-vis des générations futures et
vis-à-vis de nos partenaires européens
sur nos comptes publics car un état
endetté est un état empêché l'Europe
l'euro nous protège ce budget ambitieux
et responsable est aussi permis grâce au
soutien de l'Union européenne où en
serait notre agriculture française sans
la politique agricole commune où en
serait notre relance industrielle sans
les 40 milliards d'euros du plan fr
relance européen où en serait le
développement de nos régions rurales
sans la politique européenne de cohésion
combien payerions-nous de charg
d'intérêt de la dette sans la protection
de notre monnaie l'euro le respect de la
trajectoire des comptes publics est un
impératif catégorique pas seulement pour
le pacte européen pour les générations
futures nos enfants et nos petits
enfants qui ne nous pardonneraient pas
de vivre à crédit sur leur dos pour cela
aucun miracle aucun miracle sans
renoncer à investir il nous faut sans
cesse interroger et réinterroger la
pertinence de nos dépenses fiscales et
budgétaires je salue par conséquent
monsieur le ministre le respect de la
trajectoire de la loi de programmation
de finances publiqu à 4,4 % cette année
et souhaite que nous poursuivions
ensemble ces efforts dans les années qui
viennent nous ne pouvons pas tolérer de
laisser exploser davantage les charges
d'intérêt de la dette aujourd'hui 55
milliards d'euros ce serait demain 75
milliards devenant le premier budget de
l'État c'est vraiment insupportable en
votant ce budget vous en votant contre
ce budget vous votez donc contre la
possibilité de l'état de lever l'impôt
vous votez contre le financement des
collectivités territoriales et de la
sécurité sociale contre le plan de lutte
contre la fraude pour assurer la justice
fiscale contre l'accord international
pour l'imposition minimale des
entreprises contre la contribution sur
les rentes inframarginales des
énergéticiens autrement dit la taxe sur
les super profits que vous feignez de
réclamer vous votez contre le
verdissement de notre fiscalité contre
la mise en œuvre du crédit énergie verte
bravo chers collègues alors que
retiendra-t-on de ce budget 2024 à Tarbe
à Madiran à argelesss à maourguet à
Gavarni à lourde mes chers collègues
c'est la question qui nous intéresse
tous nous autes les députés de la nation
élus pour des idées et des valeurs mais
avant tout élu pour les gens et pour nos
territoires et bien nous retiendrons
nous retiendrons que c'est un budget
d'action historique pour le cap du plein
emploi pour le réarmement de nos
services publics et pour la
planification écologique les
entrepreneurs de ce pays nos artisans
nos commerçants nos agriculteurs nos
chefs d'entreprise nous demandent la
stabilité fiscale cela joue ne vous en
déplaise sur la confiance et vous savez
quoi cela augmente même le rendement des
impôts les recettes fiscale net de ce
budget c'est 350 milliards 17 milliards
de plus qu'en 2023 le rendement du seul
impôt sur les sociétés augmente de 11
milliards en parallèle nous poursuivons
la baisse de l'impôt de production CVAE
qui est l'ennemi de notre industrie qui
est une véritable subvention à la
délocalisation et qui est mieux que
compensé pour nos collectivités par la
TVA j'en profite cependant pour appeler
l'attention du Gouvernement sur cette
question de la prévisibilité des
recettes de compensation de la TVA pour
nos commune qui nous est vraiment
remonté du terrain le pouvoir d'achat il
reste la première préoccupation de nos
concitoyens et notre réponse c'est le
travail 2 millions d'emplois créés
depuis 2017 900000 dans l'industrie le
travail doit payer et bien c'est cette
majorité qui a augmenté le SMIC de 11 %
depuis janvier 2022 c'est ce budget qui
permet d'augmenter le SMIC et la prime
d'activité sur l'inflation pour
atteindre 1750 € bruts mensuel au 1er
janvier c'est ce budget qui indexe le
barê de l'impôt sur le revenu mais mieux
rémunérer le travail cela ne signifie
pas non plus laisser au bord du chemin
la solidarité envers celles et ceux qui
sont malades isolés en incapacité de
pouvoir travailler ou se déplacer et
bien c'est aussi ce budget qui
revalorise les prestations sociales en
circonscription comme moi j'imagine vous
êtes interpellé sur la revalorisation
des retraites et bien ce budget les
entend c'est 5,2 % de plus au 1er
janvier 4 milliards d'euros en plus pour
nos retraités modestes si notre système
de redistribution réduit l'écart entre
les revenus des 10 % les Français les
plus riches et des 10% les plus modestes
dans un rapport de 18 à 3 les inégalité
se joue à la racine dans nos quartiers
et nos ruralités et bien ce budget pour
notre jeunesse pour notre avenir
revalorise les bourses sur critères
sociaux pérénise le repas 1 € pour les
étudiants boursiers prolonge le gel des
loyers dans les résidences univ
universitaire et les droits
d'inscription à l'université madame la
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
tout cela vous votez contre enfin vous
voulez censurer la revalorisation
salariale dans la fonction publique de 5
point d'indice au 1er janvier qui veut
rendre notre fonction publique plus
attractive les services publics
justement le patrimoine de ceux qui n'en
ont pas je me suis engagé pour cela et
je suis très fier d'appartenir à une
majorité qui les réarme de manière
considérable et se donne comme priorité
de créer 1500 poste de magistrats de
greffiers d'assistants d'enquête de
brigad de gendarmerie augmente la
revalorisation augmente nos enseignants
comme jamais aucun gouvernement
auparavant ne l'a fait à 2100 € net par
mois en début de carrière 2500 € net
dans les zones REP et R plus c'est un
effort inédit consenti par notre nation
c'est aussi la généralisation des
territoires éducatifs ruraux et des
cités éducative vous votez contre la
préservation des monuments et des
monuments religieux leur restauration
avec la hausse du crédit d'impôt à 65 %
vous votez contre le soutien financier
aux collectivités le premier kilomètre
de l'action publique vous votez contre
le plan de lutte contre la violence aux
élus l'augmentation des 220 millions
d'euros de la DGF des 1,8 milliards
d'euros de décil et les 2,5 milliards
d'euros de fonds vert pour la
planification écologique enfin le plus
grand défi du temps pour notre jeunesse
c'est un effort de 10 milliards d'euros
de plus de l'État et de ses opérateurs
soit un budget qui est porté à 40
milliards d'euros pour la rénovation des
logements pour la protection de nos
forêts pour la transition de notre
agriculture pour la protection de la
biodiversité 2,2 milliards d'euros rien
que sur le plan haut ma prime rénve dans
mon seul département des Hautes Pyrénées
c'est 10000 foyers qui ont pu changer
leur chaudière c'est aussi dans ce
budget la la mise en œuvre d'une
promesse de campagne ma preadapte pour
adapter et financer les logements en
perte d'autonomie lié à l'âge où on
handicap pour les ménages les plus
modestes nous pouvons être fiers des
mesures que nous portons au bénéfice des
Français et vous chers collègues de la
France insoumise de quoi êtes-vous fier
au juste car je vous ai écouté et j'ai
lu naturellement votre motion de censure
je n''y a pas vu l'esprit de finesse
j'ai plutôt vu l'outrance le rejet
l'obstruction le refus d'obstacle en
définitive le refus d'agir car
aujourd'hui très sincèrement chers
collègues je crois que le clivage
principal dans notre société ce n'est
plus principalement le clivage gauche-
droite c'est posture ou dépassement
c'est immobilisme ou action c'est
explication simpliste ou complexe c'est
vouloir vivre des problèmes des gens ou
vouloir les régler alors vous tentez de
paralyser le pays mais vous nous
trouverez toujours devant vous debout
avec une volonté toujours plus grande de
servir et de répondre aux besoins des
Français même en majorité relative même
quand c'est difficile et bien nous
sommes unis cette majorité est unie et
ne vous laisserons pas être le
marche-pied de l'arrivée de l'extrême
droite dans notre pays la majorité
silencieuse et exigeante des Français
préférera toujours nos actions aux
postures qui sont bruyantes de ce côtéci
et le camouflage et la chaise vide de ce
côté-là je veux pour conclure saluer et
remercier notre première ministre chère
ellisabeth borne monsieur le ministre
des comptes publiques cher Thomas qui
ont le sens du dialogue et de l'intérêt
général cheville au corps ils l'ont
montré notre groupe les soutiens de
toutes ses forces et ne prendra
évidemment pas part au vote de cette
motion je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Emmanuel blairry pour le rassemblement
national
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames Messieurs les
ministre chers collègues 21 493 en 18
mois ne cherchez pas ce n'est pas un
problème mathématique c'est un problème
simplement de représentativité nationale
c'est un problème d'incapacité à écouter
ce que les Français vous disent c'est
une incapacité à discuter effectivement
des avec les oppositions et à trouver
des des compromis en le donnant pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale les
Français dans leur grande sagesse ont
voulu limiter la latitude du pouvoir
exécutif pour l'obligé à trouver des
compromis avec le pouvoir
législatif contre l'esprit de la
démocratie et de la représentation
nationale vous surexploitez le
dispositif flash du
493 lorsque la macronie défit à
l'Assemblée nationale un accord qui
apparaissait équilibré au plus grand
nombre à la sortie du Sénat elle prend
le risque de mobiliser contre elle
toutes les oppositions c'est ce qui
se'est passéit cette semaine quand
l'opposition vote en même temps c'est la
fin du en même temps on notera quand
même que les représentants des
mondialistes tellement certains de
l'issue du vote tellement arrogant
tantvers le peuple qu'envers les
oppositions n'avit même pas pris le soin
de faire le plein des voix dans ses
rangs lors de la motion de rejet du
projet de loiimmigration qu'elle manque
de
préparation la situation pourrait faire
rire si elle était sans conséquence sauf
que notre pays a besoin d'un vrai débat
démocratique notre pays a besoin de
députés et d'un gouvernement courageux
notre pays a besoin de définir et de
tenir une position claire en matière
d'immigration et pas de en même temps
notre pays a besoin d'un ministère de
l'Intérieur capable d'expulser les octtf
notre pays a besoin d'une justice ferme
qui condamne les délinquants et qui
maintient en prison ceux qui doivent y
purger leur peine nos concitoyens les
les plus plus fragiles ont besoin d'un
pays et d'une administration qui les
soutienne parmi les plus fragiles se
trouvent nos agriculteurs qui ont besoin
d'une réglementation facilitante on y
trouve aussi nos ouvriers qui ont besoin
d'usine nos chefs d'entreprisees eux ont
besoin de liberté pour développer leur
activité nous avons collectivement
besoin d'un État fort d'une
administration courageuse et d'une
justice forte avec les forts et
bienveillantes avec les plus faibles
chers collègues vous savez comme moi que
la France est le premier pays
touristique au monde en dehors de la
crise covid le tourisme représente 4 %
de notre PIB pour quelle raison à votre
avis sommes-nous la première puissance
touristique au monde tout simplement
pour la qualité de ces assiettes et la
beauté de nos paysages voilà la France
et qui fait la qualité de nos assiettes
et la beauté de nos paysages ce sont nos
agriculteurs il suffit de prendre de la
hauteur au sens propre pour se' rendre
compte le travail de la main de l'homme
en France est visible depuis l'espace
les couleurs les odeurs la terre fertile
l'engagement le dur labeur ce sont nos
agriculteurs ce sont eux les architectes
du quotidien de notre
pays je repense à cette jeune
agricultrice que j'ai rencontré à
campblin laabé sur ma circonscription
qui me faisait part de ses craintes
quant à son avenir elle souhaite
effectivement reprendre l'exploitation
de ses parents mais à quel prix elle
pourtant des idées et des projets comme
celui de robotiser la traite de
s'agrandir et de faire tous les efforts
pour répondre aux exigences
environnemental les jeunes veulent
s'engager mais ils connaissent la
précarité du monde agricole ils
connaissent d'ailleurs même le
harcèlement oui chers collègues le monde
agricole est harcelé bousculé et mis au
banc d'une disparition avec les méthode
de ce gouvernement à givanchienoble les
éleveurs m'ont parlé de l'image du monde
agricole de ce besoin d'une politique
forte pour vivre de leur production et
non d'aide qui les oblige à vivre à la
petite journée nos agriculteurs
souffrent cette phrase n'est pas un
slogan politique ce n'est pas un mot
rhtorique c'est une réalité 100000
exploitations ont mis la clé sous la
porte en 10 ans 25 % des agriculteurs
ont plus de 60 ans les moins de 40 ans
ne représentent que 14 % de la
population agricole se pose aujourd'hui
la question du remplacement des départs
en retraite avez-vous un plan madame la
Première ministre oui vous avez un plan
absolument comme vous dites mais
celui-ci vise en fait à affaiblir le
monde agricole fin des dérogations des
utilisations des néonicotinoïdes sans
alternative qui conduit à la fermeture
directement de la sucrerie des Codru
dans le crésil juste à côté de ma
circonscription crise énergétique qui
conduit à une crise des endiviers
difficulté à maintenir l'équilibre
économique d'exploitation qui qui amène
à des dépôts de bilan ou à des drames
humains le monde agricole madame la
Première ministre c'est deux suicides
par jour et pour enfoncer le clou le
gouvernement fait les poches des paysans
sous prétexte d'un verdissement de notre
économie nos paysans en vérité sont
prêts sont prêts être les acteurs
principaux de la souveraineté
alimentaire ils sont prêts aux enjeux de
de demain la réponse se trouve dans le
localisme effectivement produire local
consommer local vous le refusez
aujourd'hui nous le ferons demain avec
Marine Le Pen toute la classe politique
fait le même constat les membres de la
majorité et les ministres ne cessent de
répéter qu'ils soutiennent les
agriculteurs mais rien n fait lorsque
vous proposez des réformes ou des
engagements ce sont nos paysans qui
subissent alors que la guerre en Ukraine
a fait exploser les les prix en matière
les matières premières alors que les
prix des énergies fossiles et de
l'électricité se sont envolé à cause du
marché européen appliqué une
idéologiquement je dirais même et même m
vous Dirz progressivement puisque vous
avez un petit peu changé de de méthode
entre deux le GNR ressemble furusement
aujourd'hui à de l'acharnement envers le
monde agricole cet hiver vous avez
demandé aux éleveurs de couper
l'électricité l'été vous demandez au
mêmes éleveurs aux agriculteurs en
général de baisser la consommation d'eau
et maintenant vous en prenez directement
à leur porte-monnaie vous décidez
d'appliquer les augmentation du GNR en
période de crise des prix alors qu'en
fait il faudrait au moins les geler
jusqu qu'à ce que la situation
économique se stabilise lorsque ce soir
mesdames messieurs membres du
gouvernement vous serez à tablé vous
aurez une pensée pour nos agriculteurs
ceux même qui font la qualité de nos
assiettes et la beauté de nos paysages
ceux qui contribue à faire la France de
la France le premier pays touristique au
monde mais l'indescence ne s'arrête pas
là d'une part le gouvernement je viens
d'en parler supprime les exonérations de
taxes sur le GNR d'autre part le
gouvernement fait adopter en catimini
via ce 493 dont il a le secret un
amendement FIFA qui va exonérer d'impôts
les fédérations sportives
internationales qui s'installeraient à
Paris et d'impôt sur le revenu leur
salariés qui touchent des rémunérations
exorbitantes voilà le cadeau fiscal fait
à la FIFA alors même où de nombreux
Français vont devoir se serrer la
ceinture à Noël je le dis et je le
répète votre gouvernement ferait mieux
de s'occuper des Français qui se lèvent
tôt pour travailler pour faire vivre ce
pays plutôt que de raser gratis les
chasseurs de prime à un moment où notre
dette publique s'élève à 3000 milliards
d'euros Emmanuel Macron le Mozart de la
finance fait sombrer dans la France dans
un état de quasi faillite et nous
prépare un destin à la grecque son quoi
qu'il en coûte est en fait devenu en
vérité un quoi qui vous en coûte chers
français notre pouvoir exécutif est
complètement déconnecté des réalités des
Français alors certes on entend partout
c'est l'élite intellectuelle de la
France elle a fait ses classes à
scienceep et Alena avant d'accéder au
pouvoir elle travaillait dans des
cabinets en banque ou dans la com bien
qu'elle ne pense rien à voir à apprendre
des petites gens elle ne sait pas ce que
c'est d'être à découvert le 10 du mois
parce que l'inflation a rendu les
produits du quotidien les fruits les
légumes inabordables et parce que
aujourd'hui encore le gasoil dépasse
encore les 1,70 € à bapomme c'est au
cours de la présidence d'Emmanuel Macron
que le mouvement des gilets jaunes a
pris de l'ampleur mettant en lumière le
décalage existant entre nos élites
parisiennes d'une part et les gens
normaux qui travaillent sans parvenir
parfois à boucler leur fin de mois ce
n'est pas la nupè si elle existe encore
qui va défendre le sort des classes
populaires et des classe moyenne parce
que la gauche a abandonné en vérité les
classes populaires et dans le même temps
elle a PL à voter pour Emmanuel Macron
enfin je voudrais rappeler que le groupe
eren s'est battu avec force et en faveur
de nos concitoyens ultramarins de
manière transpartisane nous avons tiré
la sonnette d'alarme sur les faiblesses
des infrastructures d'eau et
d'assaainissement notamment en
Guadeloupe et à Mayotte nous avons
proposé de relever le chèque alimentaire
pour Mayotte vous l'avez refusé qui fait
face à une véritable situation d'urgence
humanitaire en plus de l'urgence
migratoire quant à la guyan nous avons
proposé de renforcer l'opération harpi
qui lutte depuis 2008 contre le F fléo
pardon de leur paillage illégal qu'il
convient d'éradiquer comme l'ont
souligné en nous rejoignant sur ce point
plusieurs élus
d'outrem CE SOIR ceux qui espéraient
quelque chose de la macronie sont une
fois de plus déçus les Français
l'observent et le déplorent c'est dans
les urnes qu'ils pourront prendre leur
destin en main j'ai une pensée ce soir
toute particulière pour nos concitoyens
qui malgré les difficultés financières
essaieront à l'UR prochain d'offrir un
rveillon de Noël un Noël Noël c'est la
fête de la lumière au cœur de l'hiver
c'est l'étoile qui brille faiblement
dans la nuit noire et puis Noël nous
rappelle aussi qu'il existe toujours un
espoir alors avec un peu d'avance je
souhaite à l'ensemble des Français de
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année je vous
remercie je vous remercie pour terminer
cette discussion général la parole est à
Monsieur Nicolas du
ponignan madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre chers collègues
21493 en 18 mois du jamais vu sous la 5e
République imaginez-vous sérieusement
madame la Première ministre
finir le quinquena avec à ce rythme près
d'une soixantaine de 493 à votre actif
des 493 de surcroix enclenché avant même
la discussion des amendements
interdisant tout débat dans l'hémicycle
croyez-vous sincèrement que les Français
accepteront longtemps docilement un tel
dénis de démocratie à répétition comme
je vous l'ai déjà dit à cette tribune à
maint reprise vous n'avez jamais digérer
le vote des Français aux élections
législatives de juin 2022 vous passez
votre temps à répéter que vous voulez
des compromis mais les Français ont bien
vu que vous n'en faisiez jamais vous
avez même supprimé de ce projet de loi
des amendements provenant du MoDem votre
propre majorité non content d'user et
d'abuser du 493 vous avez d'ailleurs eu
le culot de crier au scandale
démocratique ce lundi suite à l'adoption
salutaire de la motion de rejet du
projet de loi immigration quel comble se
plaindre d'une absence de débat le lundi
et dégainer le 21e 493 le jeudi vous
n'avez plus aucune crédibilité votre
gouvernement n'a plus aucune crédibilité
vos ministres d'ailleurs le savent et
vous rappelle à l'ordre Monsieur le
Maire avec le président de la République
vous êtes au fond et vous le savez tous
sur les bans de ce gouvernement dans une
impasse total seul l'arbitrage du peuple
Français par référendum ou par des
élections législatives ou même par une
élection présidentielle anticipée peut
résoudre le conflit de légitimité entre
un président à bout de souffle et une
assemblée il faut bien le reconnaître
ingouvernable mes chers collègues la
question fondamentale est donc de savoir
si vous souhaitez continuer à vous
épuiser inutilement en discutant avec un
gouvernement de mauvaise foi qui fait
tant de mal au pays au risque d'ailleurs
de couler avec lui ou si au contraire fr
vous faites preuve de courage en votant
la censure qui obligerait Emmanuel
Macron à oser la dissolution qui ne
manquera pas de venir j'en suis certain
la gravité des problèmes du pays les
souffrances des Français nous obligent à
agir vite n'attendons pas 2027 chaque
mois de perdu AG grave la déliquessence
sans précédent de notre nation
submersion migratoire avec l'arrivée
chaque année de 500000 étrangers sans
compter les clandestins rendant
impossible l'intégration et la paix
civile insécurité croissante rendant
invivable le quotidien dans No nombreux
quartiers et donnant un sentiment de
toutepissance aux barbares qui tiennent
la rue perte de substances économiques
notamment de nos agriculteur qui souffre
et qui manifeste dans l'indifférence
générale avec un fossé toujours plus
grand entre le discours de la
réindustrialisation de la relocalisation
et la pratique des délocalisations
aboutissant même à ce que dans les les 2
tiers des pharmacies françaises il n'y
ait plus d'amoxicyine pour les enfants
c'est ça la réalité de votre politique
inégalité sociale exacerbé avec une
baisse historique du pouvoir d'achat un
record de pauvreté et toujours plus
d'argent pour l'oligarchie qui est votre
maître abandon des ultramarins qui
souffrent et qui n'ont même pas d'eau
potable enfin souousmission généralisée
à une union européenne autoritaire assez
folle pour prévoir de donner 100 86
milliards d'euros dont 2 32 à la charge
des Français pour l'élargissement à
l'Ukraine et nous devrions attendre
sagement 2026 en vous subissant ce
serait un crime de non assistance à
Nation en danger car oui si nous
continuons dans cet hémicycle les
petites soupes sur les petits feux
Emmanuel Macron nous laissera un champ
de ruine seul des élections législatives
anticipées permettrai aux Français de
choisir une majorité
une vraie alternative politique capable
enfin de s'attaquer à la racine des
problèmes français une vraie alternative
rassemblant les patriotes les amoureux
de la France les goolistes qui dans
quantité de domaines clés comme la
sécurité la création de richesse
l'immigration la restructuration des
services publics l'aménagement du
territoire l'indépendance nationale
partage l'essentiel en commun lundi soir
lundi dernier pour une fois les Français
étaient fiers de notre assemblée alors
aujourd'hui prenons nos responsabilités
pour leur rendre le pouvoir et les
laisser enfin choisir la politique
qu'ils souhaitent pour sortir de
l'impasse dans lequel vous avez mis le
pays je vous
remercie la parole est à madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les
Députés je ne dirai que quelques mots de
cette première partie du projet de loi
de finance pour
2024 les orateurs de la majorité en ont
parfaitement rappelé les contours et les
principales
mesures cette première partie du budget
est nécessaire pour donner des moyens à
l'ensemble de nos services publics et de
nos politiques elle met en uvre un
engagement clé que nous avons pris
devant les Français pas de hausse
d'impôt elle prévoit des mesures
importantes pour le logement pour le
pouvoir d'achat pour la transition
écologique pour les outrem pour une
politique de la ville ambitieuse pour
nos agriculteurs pour les communes
rurales ou pour la lutte contre la
fraude elle a été amendée grâce à des
propositions de la majorité comme des
oppositions de l'Assemblée nationale
comme du Sénat je pense à l'extension du
prêt à tau zéro grâce à ce texte il sera
ouvert à 6 millions de Français
supplémentaires les Français des classes
moyennes je pense à la réforme des zones
de revitalisation rurale attendu par les
élus ruraux comme je comme je m'y étais
engagé devant l'Association des maires
de France grâce à ce texte le zonage
sera étendu à 4000 communes
supplémentaires mais malheureusement
comme d'habitude ces mesures n'étaient
au cœur ni de votre motion de censure ni
de vos prises de parole au fil de vos
interventions j'ai écouté les mêmes
arguments entendus et
réentendus et ce soir plusieurs d'entre
vous ont encore osé taxer le
gouvernement de déis démocratie pourtant
mesdames et messieurs les députés sans
sur vos manœuvres et vos indignations
surjouées ne trompent personne avec la
majorité avec mon gouvernement nous
n'avons pas de leçon de concertation à
recevoir de la part de ceux qui refusent
toute recherche d'accord avec la avec la
majorité avec mon gouvernement nous
n'avons pas de leçon de débat à recevoir
alors même que vous répondez à chaque
budget par des motions de rejet et des
motions de censure avec la majorité avec
mon gouvernement nous n'avons pas de
leçon de parlementarisme à recevoir de
la de la part de députés insoumis qui
n'ont que les outrance à la bouche avec
la majorité avec mon gouvernement nous
n'avons aucune leçon à voir dans la
lutte contre l'extrême droite alors que
vous vous alliez régulièrement que vous
alliez régulièrement vos voix à celle du
rassemblement national régulièrement
vous faites front commun l'extrême
gauche pour provoquer le blocage et
l'extrême droite pour en récolter les
fruits vous dites vous opposez mais dans
cette assemblée bien souvent les
extrêmes se font à la courte
échelle mesdames et messieurs les
députés depuis plus de 18 mois sur tous
les textes nous avançons nous
construisons certains tentent de
rabaisser le travail parlementaire la
réalité est ailleurs le Parlement
fonctionne malgré toutes les tentatives
de certains depuis plus de 18 mois nous
avons construit des majorités avec des
parlementaires de tous les groupes de
l'arc républicain près de 60 textes ont
été adoptés sans recourir au 493 des
textes important portant des mesures
fortes encore récemment pour le plein
emploi pour le pouvoir d'achat pour le
Bien Vieillir bien sûr chacun sait qu'il
en va autrement pour les textes
budgétaires depuis les communes jusqu'à
notre Parlement voter un budget et la
marque d'appartenance à une majorité ou
à une
opposition je peux regretter que cette
usage nous empêche de construire un
accord sur le budget mais je ne le
conteste pas en revanche j'en tiens les
conclusions qui s'imposent et en
responsabilité j'utilise les outils que
notre Constitution nous donne nous
respectons ses principes à la lettre
comme l'a affirmé le Conseil
constitutionnel hier c'est une réponse
claire aux apprentis constitutionnaliste
du rassemblement
national mesdames et messieurs les
députés rien n'atteindra ma
détermination ni les invectives ni les
outrances ni les motions de censure à
répétition ni encore moins les alliances
entre les extrêmes au contraire cela
renforce ma volonté d'agir avec le
gouvernement avec toute la majorité au
service des Français je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre la discussion est
close je vais maintenant mettre au voix
la motion de censure le scrutin est
annoncé dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale je rappelle que seuls les
députés favorables à la motion de
censure participent au scrutin et que le
vote se déroule dans les salles voisines
de l'hémicycle s'il vous plaît madame la
Première ministre la séance n'est pas
levée madame tevenau monsieur le
ministre
le scrutin est ouvert pour une durée de
20 minutes il sera donc clos à 20h20 la
séance est
suspendue mes chers collègues la séance
est reprise voici le résultat du scrutin
majorité requise pour l'adoption de la
motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 289 pour l'adoption 75 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée en
conséquence la première partie du projet
de de finances pour 2024 est considéré
comme adopté en nouvelle lecture